it's time for roses and Rosie tonight we
got to talk about vomit yes we had the
Tuesday night episode of bachelor in
paradise plus the after-show and it was
a lot of continuation of Monday night's
dramas but I didn't have a problem with
it because it was amazing
guys Evan and Carly are becoming a very
real storyline I mean we continue to see
the fallout of Carly and Evans habanero
Guinness Book of World Records string of
spit of world record date and that meant
more talk about how Carly bombed after
the tape yeah
so Carly makes a great observation about
Evan who is the runner of an erectile
disfunction clinic back home
she says he's only concentrating on
men's boners he's not concentrating on a
lady barn which really does blow my mind
cheers to an observation not just about
Evan but I think about much of mankind
50/50 is how it should be guys okay
we're gonna cheers tonight to every
legitimate observation made by a
bachelor paradise cast member yet ready
for a drinking game so Carly isn't up
breaking up with Evan on Tuesday nights
AB and Evan Christ
but then Evan becomes Oprah yeah you
know Oprah had vision boards Evan writes
himself
I'm in right since an inspirational note
something like flipped inside me and it
drives him to go on and next week he
plans to pursue Amanda because yeah Josh
Marie and Evan they're in the same
league you know what cheers Evans making
a good observation about yourself you
knew you needed to write yourself a go
Evan note my favorite part when he said
you're freaking Evan bass you got this
Oh moving right along
so Amanda and Josh are still going hot
and heavy literally they can't stop
putting their faces together and making
out uh speaking of vomit and except that
josh has a steady diet of Amanda's
tongue can we talk about the noises Josh
makes honey kisses people very deep
very deep it's like it
I can't tell is the show adding in those
noises or is that really gosh yeah let
me know your thoughts I'd love to hear
so Amanda and Josh are making out grant
and lace are making out and Vinny and
Izzy are making out and they become the
sexy six oh my god the sexy six you know
not a great observation but a great
nickname and I'll cheers to that
I have never seen people make out so
boldly so close to each other maybe in
middle school uh we have the twins the
poor little twins all that matters is
that they're twins twins twins twins we
just talked about the mean twins they
even swapped with each other on a date
tonight to try to confuse the guys like
twins
Barry Parent Trap Barry it takes to
ferry twins obviously the movie twins
Irish horse singer dated of you not
really twins
I get it cheers for me making that
observation Thanks cheers to another
great observation somebody finally
brought up the elephant in the room the
Zika virus Zika very Zika virus yeah
Daniel I don't know about this excuse
but Daniel said that he didn't want to
make out with Sara because he felt a
cold coming on and was worried he would
maybe have think of our Zika virus and
pass it to her
that's gentlemanly you know you can say
a lot of things about this show but
don't say it's not relevant
next up the after show comes out of the
pan as an abduction into the show
business
I didn't say ever the singer so the
after show brought the return of the man
who will never die as hard as he tries
literally to kill himself with
drunkenness and so much cigarette
smoking Chad Chad was back and Chad was
being his pretty normal self clad in
black a la Johnny Cash vape in hand he
met up with Sarah on the after show for
their first face-to-face discussion I am
sorry
now Sarah just wanted a real apology we
know this because we interview her and
she told us and actually she gave us a
little shout-out on after Paradise I
mean I know you apologized on Eid
babe what's up Sara Sara got her apology
from Chad I apologize for real I guess
but more importantly we saw some
bachelor in paradise lost footage
deleted seats they have a lot of footage
that they can't show for attacking
straights which showed lace really
looking out for Chad hey cheers to a
good observation by lace Chad was too
drunk boohoo I gotta careful mm-hmm side
nope
Spencer Pratt also called in because
he's a bachelor nation super Vance and
he defended chat and had a lot to say
and they didn't give him enough air time
so Spencer if you want where your time
come on this show we love you another
side okay another side note the show did
a poll of viewers asking them who they
think Amanda should be with team Nick
team Josh or team Evans Nick won by 82%
I get it
Nick is very likeable this season he
really seems genuine he's being cool
with everybody I like Nick Josh Josh
we're gonna have to wait and see but I
think him and man to really do each
other
what do you guys think that's kind of a
big question right now and that's what
they tease for next week
is Josh being genuine do you think he is
let me know on twitter i'm at lauren
zima and be sure to subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel to continue to watch all
the bachelor franchises with us all
seasons here they're out all year long